toutes ces histoires nous mettons en
lumière les génies qui peuplent la
télévision et on va commencer avec les
grands esprits de la bataille des
couples sur tf6
je vais faire un petit clin d'oeil aux
couples chloé et virgile alors qu il
dirige il s'est noyé virgile ce sont eux
merci en régie merci voilà comme virgile
vous allez faire un petit clin d'oeil
vous avez l'habitude maintenant quand
chloé ne passe pas son temps à crier sur
son mec elle passe son temps à le
dézinguer à regarder même quand elle
fait un effort
même quand elles essayent de défendre
son fiancé et ben lui balance une grosse
cartouche comme ça gratos c'est parti
c'est les aînés du bas jan ça lui plaît
pas du tout que vivier ne soit pas très
bon dans la pétanque forcément c'est un
compétiteur et lu jusqu'au bout
j'essaie un peu le détendre quoi il fait
pas exprès d'être mauvais il est mauvais
le port
on dirait dans les bronzés québec est
mauvaise pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas encore je vous présente et maxime
maxime il fait de la télé réalité mais
c'est certain son rêve ultime c'est de
devenir animateur de club de vacances
notamment faut mettre une photo
résultats partout tout le temps même
quand on lui demande rien ce gars là il
faut mettre de l'ambiance
c'est le gars et me mettre de l'ambiance
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps c'est un peu relou à frère el
roque et lage aujourd'hui l'aise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
alors ça c'est la bataille des coûts
c'est sur tf6
s'ils font partie des génies du pass
parce que tous les soirs enfin débridée
génie du paf et vous prenez sinon la
bataille des couples vous leur a ajouté
l'action du sud et ça devient des
marseillais double
est ce que vous connaissez de faire
beaucoup y est couillet vous fera voir
oui tu couilles warawa alors ces
nouveaux verbes à la mode chez les
marseillais d'ailleurs mon ami et nos
amis pagaille manon ils passent leur
temps à couillet regardez
il faut pas qu'on coûte trop alors
on n'a pas le choix parce que si on
attendait d'eux qu'ils font ça pour
égaliser 6 heures la carte
mais si je le bats a fait 3 contre 5
c'est pour ça qu'il faut construire
sacrifier les marseillais lorsque vous
connaissez la chaîne idf1
bien sûr oui il ya de la brillance et ça
fait plusieurs jours qu'une certaine
solange appelle la chaîne idf1 pour
avoir des nouvelles de son ex qui
s'appelle meidhi petit message si
solange nous regarde
il faut qu'elle nous appelle parce que
les pauvres les voyants d'idf1
ils sont au bout du rouleau avec m
regardez son prénom solange et s'il vous
plaît oui j'ai pas bien compris et son
prénom c'est il m'a dit c'est ça ma et
10 miles les mailles dit son âge révolu
s'il vous plaît solange m'a dit oui à
son âge s'il vous plaît bybee et
maybelline et le pen aujourd'hui 66
devant lui 16 septembre 70 c'est que
vous connaissez depuis combien de temps
[Applaudissements]
la dent mailly ils habitent ou marie et
sexy exceptionnel ça on peut regarder ça
des heurts avec les équipes vous savez
tpp égale générosité l'avait encore une
fois est alors forcément quand
l'émission se termine on se propose
d'envoyer gratuitement la régie de ses
huit à idf1 voilà c'est la cadeau pour
nous puisque pas de bol
vraiment ils jouent une régie c'est pire
que nous regarder en fin d'émission
allez on commence comme une forme à
prendre la première appelle tout de
suite
alors bonjour à l'eau là c'est toujours
comme ça c'est parti pour un prochain
appel à l'aube au jour à l'eau un
service gagnant titre italo bonjour à
l'eau et wynants contente pas du tout
pourri la campagne de mails à rien du
tout zineb rien d'accord ah ben ça a
coupé dans les junies du paf
hier soir il ya des rambo rands 2,3 sur
ces 8 qui a très bien marché et plus
d'un million sans mettre les spectateurs
et pour le plaisir on avait envie de
vous remontrer la plus belle scène du
film je veux a surpassé je vous le dis
30 fois hier il ya même des gens je vous
le dis à gâteau pro le croyais que
c'était une vanne
je pensais que je suppose que c'est une
vanne ne pensais que c'était pas
vraiment pensé que c'était moi qui
l'avais écrit regardez d'accord je
savais que mon pied
alors où est ce que les missiles sont
locales ici tout près où ça
tant que les scénaristes c'est sûr et
sauf un qui il était en retard car ils
ont des manières on met quoi les
missiles et tous et l'autre à 10 dans
ton cul tu sais quoi
tu sais que c'est peut-être peut-être
combat de m et en fait ils ont dû à
l'évasion manager jean rivard voir parce
que le début est tellement sérieux
d'accord je savais que mme antier alors
où est ce que les missiles sont locales
s'y tromperait où ça
[Applaudissements]
on est allé sur tf1 on a regardé aussi
animal académie où il ya déjà alors sans
gros c'est comme mousse mais sans
mathieu delormeau ça pour faire du le
classe ils ont engagé avec sa pelle les
rendront chez un dresseur brésilien qui
est censé nous apprendre à communiquer
avec nos amis à quatre pattes
alors j'espère que les chiens ils
veulent comprendre parce que là on
comprend pas tout ce qu'il dit mais on
aime bien regarder
clairement je travaille toute la journée
donc je promène le soir quand je rentre
du travail
en fait une oie léandre je comprends
bien qu'il ya des fois que vous besoin
travail et qui vous pouvez pas les
promener et ne comprend pas ça
gptd d'accord on va passer à la suivante
est ce qu'il faut c'est des faux léo-guy
d'or cent est ce que vous les promelles
suivant j'imagine pas qui le bat
s'échapper de vous des quarts c'est au
cas où c'est rassurant
[Musique]
à lui dû s'arrêter là moi j'ai quitté
très sympathique j'ai un chien je vais
l'appeler pour qu'il s'en occuper
à la demande générale hier on vous
parlait d'un reportage diffusé dans 90
minutes enquête la police a reçu une
plainte
incroyable et un membre des forces de
l'ordre par seront sur place pour voir
de quoi il en retourne une intervention
à haut risque nous avait demandé de
revoir la séquence
je vous le dis éloignez les enfants très
très sensibles s'abstenir c'est une des
plus grosses interventions policières de
ces quinze dernières années
in et si kevin je vous le dis est ce que
vous êtes sensibles je suis très
sensible c'est vrai on va vous montrer
sa part toi mais une pizzeria pour
laquelle il a reçu une plainte d'un
client
c'est une personne qui m'a commandé une
pizza quatre fromages et qui au final
ans avec 3 sur sa pizza
donc bon bah
c'est vrai que
si la personne ne s'attendait à voir une
pizza 80 il faut qu'un et 4 dessus donc
on va les regarder ça et en profiter
pour faire un contrôle complet sur place
à l'heure après un contrôle d'hygiène
etc
ça c'était complètement fou dont égale
m6 visiblement mac lesggy a fait passer
un message aux scientifiques de
l'émission je vous le dis il a dû leur
dire déjà que raconter des trucs
personne ne comprend c'est compliqué
donc essayé au moins d'être un peu plus
cool à l'image donc regarder désormais
des clauses scientifique repère la
caméra il fait un sourire de ou
s'agit-il d'une marque d'ennuis comme le
pensent certains poulies nous avons posé
la question au docteur stéphane clerget
6 4
aurélien digne à jo c'est que vos
tristes nous les présente le docteur
charles mellerio neuroradiologue nous
répond
et enfin c'était le 12 octobre
et qu'est ce qui se passe tous les 12
octobre tous les 12 octobre il se passe
quelque chose c'est le jour de
l'hispanité l'hispanité c'est la fête
nationale en espagne motivé tous les ans
le 2 octobre je me rends en espagne bien
sûr je fais de cette fête
ouais j'adore c'est comme le 14 juillet
en france on rigole on mange de la
paella si génial affaire est un peu quoi
est ce que c'est la feria non c'est la
sellette jour de l'hispanité et des jeux
natalité alors nous c'était qu'à paris
on a eu la chance d'avoir l'homme volant
francky zapata oui eh ben madrid 2 ils
ont eu francky chat passe pas regardez
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bana je lui en téléphone je l'aimé bien
regarder la tête des officiels pour la
voir la nouvelle vague il ay voir des
familles celle des médias il ya viol
chaque fois regardez regardez au chenil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]